Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Brian Karem, who's an award winning
journalist and author of the new book Free
The Press, The Death of American Journalism
and How to Revive It.
Great.
Great having you on, Brian.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Thanks.
Pleasure being here.
Speaker 1: So, OK.
I mean, when did the death of American journalism
start with?
Was there a particular period where we can
start to see this demise?
Speaker 4: Sure.
I blame Richard Nixon and Roger Ailes, both
camps of the devil who one came into office
and, you know, committed as many crimes as
he could and the other attached to him and
eventually spawned Mitch McConnell and Fox
News.
So those two together began our journey in
that it was Ronald Reagan who actually implemented
the first seeds of planted the seeds of destruction
and every.
Every president in the last 40 years has had
their hand in doing it, some more than others,
some less.
Speaker 1: And when we say the death of journalism,
I mean, in a literal sense, we have media
outlets, we have people called reporters in
all of these things.
So like, what?
What are you talking about?
What is it that has that has degenerated?
Speaker 4: Well, the term for one, you know,
to be a reporter, you have to at least have
at least one copy editor.
Otherwise you just some idiot spouting your
opinion.
And it's OK.
I'm all fond of, you know, opinions.
But to be a journalist, you have to vet facts
and the process of how we do that is broken
down over the years, how we do it.
The institution is falling apart.
Look, there's vast media.
The biggest problem.
The underlying largest problem in the United
States with journalism is a lack of community
journalism.
There are vast informational deserts, news
deserts in this country, thousands of communities
where there is no local news.
And until we fix that problem, we can't fix
the bigger problem.
The smaller problem has to be fixed with investing
in community newspapers, giving tax breaks
to small business owners.
You know what's wrong with a $100 rebate on
your taxes?
If you simply if you can prove you subscribe
to a newspaper or a radio station or something,
that's that's where you start.
Because.
And look, governments over the last 40 years,
state, local and federal have gotten rid of
public notice ads, and those are probably
one of the key things that you need to build
newspapers.
In fact, those those public notice ads provide
transparency on government.
Everybody can pick it up and go, Oh, look,
here's in the states of the City Council's
meeting Friday, and salesmen would use those
and lawyers would use them to find clients
and to find people to relate with in the community.
And all of that help build our communities
at the national level.
We divide our communities by going, you know,
right or left.
But at the local level, everybody wants a
paved street.
Everybody wants their, you know, the water
to work, the lights, the work.
You know, the schools to work, hospitals,
police, all of those things that we have it,
you know, Hey, why is that stoplight not working?
We show up at a City Council meeting and find
out.
But all of those things have kind of broken
down over the years because of a lack of local
and community newspapers.
And until we fix that.
And by the way, that's where most national
story start is with community journalism.
They start there.
And until we invest in community journalism,
we're not going to solve our problems.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So I mean, there's so many different areas
that are factors here, and I'll just name
some of them.
And then maybe you could tell us whether these
are things that could be solved individually
or whether they're really all part of the
same thing.
So you've got.
OK.
On the one hand, you've got the internet,
which has created essentially this model where
at very little cost, you can essentially rewrite
and do reporting by phone rather than doing
real investigative journalism that has put
pressure on newspapers and other other media
outlets to say, Well, let's let, let's divest
from the expensive investigative journalists
and instead do this thing.
So that's one thing.
Let me mention a couple of others.
Speaker 4: All right.
Well, you address them one by one.
Oh, OK.
So I don't forget it in that regard.
The internet is a great thing.
What newspapers and television and radio and
traditional media did wrong was to get tied
into the perpetual news cycle so that we can
vet facts and people look.
People scream to the left and the right that
we're that we're biased, you know, conservatively
or biased.
Liberals know we're biased towards money,
right?
Constriction of the business.
We go where the money is.
Yes.
You end up with news that you want rather
than news that you need.
And that's the danger of that was a management
problem.
And that's because we have fewer experienced
people in this business anymore who can fend
off the the need to go first.
Oh, they're showing up.
Like we have to do is take a look at the Steele
dossier, for example.
All right.
The Steele dossier came out in the very first
report said not vetted.
This is not vetted information.
And yet everyone ran with it as if it were
right.
The problem?
So the internet isn't a problem, it's a solution
with the right people behind it.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt so.
So that's one piece of the technological factors
that have changed things.
Second, we look at some other countries.
There's a fee everybody pays towards public
broadcasting.
For example, you talk about what about $100
tax credit if you subscribe to this or that.
We also then have the entire debate around,
Hey, you get a basic cable package and some
number of bucks is going to Fox News or whatever.
Even if you don't want it to and so people
are paying often for so-called news that they
don't even actually want.
So there's that structural issue that needs
to be looked at as well, it seems to me.
Speaker 4: Well, the problem there is.
You need to reinstitute the fairness doctrine
so that you know what has happened in a recent
press conference, President Biden referred
to it as informational alleys that we go into
alleys where we hear what we want to hear
and not what we need to hear.
And I call it in the book Informational Silos.
We're all kind of siloed into our own existence,
and we never hear what anybody else is saying.
Sure.
Well, the Fairness Doctrine helped increase
public news.
I mean, it helped spawn the news industry.
And so when you reinstitute a fairness doctrine,
so you have to listen to at least listen to
the other side on matters of import.
Then perhaps you can break down some of those
informational silos.
Speaker 1: From what I've read, though, the
the fairness doctrine, as it previously existed,
would essentially have no teeth in them in
an age where so much is.
I mean, you need something different.
You need something different because of the
internet, right?
Speaker 4: Well, and that's one of the things
I say in the book is you need to have a blue
ribbon commission to look at it.
You need to institute the fairness doctrine.
But you need people in this industry and lawmakers
to assess how we can do it, you know, so that
it makes a difference.
The real problem?
The fairness doctrine never really had teeth.
I mean, never did.
No one was ever lost a, you know, a license
because they didn't adhere to the fairness
doctrine.
It's just that it kind of gave us all a guardrail
that we could all aim for.
And so public service programing, public affairs
programing, news all was spawned by that.
It started in 1949 under the Truman administration,
and people said, Yeah, OK.
You know, they said, we're going to sell you
the airwaves, but for one hour a day or whatever,
you got to do public news.
And so that was kind of without any, you know,
real consequence to it.
People fell in line.
You need that today.
You need at least a guardrail and then discuss
how you can make the guard real solid.
But yeah, it doesn't.
Yeah, it won't work.
You can't just go.
All right.
Reinstate the fairness doctrine as it existed.
That won't work, but you need some form of
fairness doctrine to make sure that and make
sure that it does work.
Speaker 1: What about the socio cultural shift
that has taken place in terms of attitudes
towards news?
And this includes two pieces.
One is lack of media literacy, where people
can't even tell whether they're watching news
or opinion.
So that's one side people not really understanding
what it is that they're watching.
The other side is this sort of contempt, and
we could.
I'm curious to hear from you how responsible
Trump was for this or others about if it's
adversarial and you don't like it, it's fake
or they're lying or they're biased or whatever.
To what degree is that change in the attitude
towards what news is a problem here?
Speaker 4: Well, taking your last one first
Trump was a symptom, not a cause.
Trump is a con man who used existing differences
and division and further exploited them, as
he told.
You know, I can't remember who he told, but
he said, Look, I tell people that you're the
fake news, so they don't believe you, right?
You know, don't.
That's old.
That's really an old tactic, you know, embodied
in the statement.
Don't shoot the messenger.
You know, we're just giving it to your about.
You don't like it.
Too bad.
Go clean it up.
It's not upon us to say now we've lost.
I think to your first part, what we've lost
over the years is there's a lack of institutional
knowledge.
And because of that lack of institutional
knowledge caused by the constriction in our
business and that constriction in our business
was caused by the fact that when I first got
in this business, there were maybe two dozen
companies that ran 80 percent of what you
see reader here today, there's five that commandeer
about 90 percent of what you see or hear,
right?
And that's because we removed the restrictions
on ownership.
And so what happened was is larger and larger
companies began to buy each other up and as
they did, bottom line counted more.
There were fewer reporters, like if you owned
a media conglomerate that used to be comprised
of four different or five different or a hundred
different newspapers who all had reporters
in Washington, D.C. for their specific newspaper,
you would go, Well, I can save money by just
having one reporter there, right?
Got rid of a lot of jobs and experience, and
it became more popular.
When I first got in this business, you had
to have three to five years experience working
as a beat reporter somewhere in a small market.
So you understood what it was to be a reporter.
Right?
Today, they hire you straight out of school
and will hire you and put you in the White
House with no experience at all.
And therefore, we lose our credibility because
what you end up with are reporters without
experience who are more, you know, they're
more susceptible to the access journalism.
Oh, I won't be able to get on Air Force One.
Oh, I won't be allowed into this room.
Oh, I won't be able to talk to these people
if I do this.
So that's led to what is a disgustingly low
level of real report.
Awarding it in the United States, and it's
only going to get worse if we don't fix it,
you know, it was in 1958 that Edward R. Murrow,
appearing before the Radio Television News
Directors Association, warned us that if we
don't clean up our act, we are destined to
fall for nothing but slogans and propaganda
in the future.
And by God, yeah, we nailed it.
Speaker 1: So what's the lowest hanging fruit?
Because you've got the media literacy piece,
you've got the media consolidation and lack
of enforcement of antitrust piece.
You've got regulatory FCC net neutrality,
fairness doctrine aspect of this.
There's all these different things.
What's the lowest hanging fruit that would
have the greatest impact, most quickly?
Speaker 4: Community newspapers invest in
them and give tax breaks for them and encourage
them.
And that's where you start, because that's
where you build reporters.
Some of the best reporters look.
Why did Walter Cronkite have so much gravitas?
In 1965, I think it was when he went to Vietnam
and he developed.
He put together a documentary which was all
fact based, and then at the end of it, he
offered an opinion.
It's not unusual for reporters to offer opinions.
He offered one, he said.
It's obvious to this report that we're not
going to win.
We've got to negotiate our way out of it.
And LBJ said, I've lost Middle America, I've
lost Cronkite.
I'm doomed.
I got, you know, I won't run for reelection.
Why did people why do people respect that
opinion?
Well, because Walter Cronkite had the gravitas
to to be able to say it.
He had covered World War Two.
He was a radio beat reporter.
He had experience upon experience, upon experience.
What anchor today on any news show has that
what?
What would tell it?
What newspaper writer today has the gravitas
of an H.L.
Mencken?
We don't have that because we have lost institutional
knowledge.
When you when it costs too much to have a
reporter around, they find other ways to make
money.
Because guess what?
By the time you're in your mid thirties or
forties and you got a family, you can't exist
on what they're going to pay you in this business
Speaker 1: as a reporter.
So if I understand the community newspaper,
community media outlet piece, it's good because
number one, it creates more diversity of opinion.
It's good because number two, it trains reporters
to be ready to go to the national level.
Number three, it's good because financially
it's it's dividing money up among more institutions
like there's a bunch of different ways in
which that is a positive thing.
Right?
Speaker 4: I agree.
And yeah, yeah, I agree because I wrote it.
But but the and then there are other things
you don't like the reinstitution.
I think you need a national shield law to
protect reporters so they don't go to jail.
They have confidential sources.
As a reporter who was jailed four times, I
can tell you it's not fun.
And then the most controversial thing in the
thing that's that hurts and bites the most
for businesses, you know, using antitrust
legislation to bust up the big monopolies.
Right?
But it has to be done in some respects, somehow,
and that's why you need a blue ribbon commission
to decide how to do it.
You have to have more reporters on the planet.
There are twice the number of people on this
planet.
Today is on the day that I was born.
And probably about half the number of reporters.
That's a problem.
Right.
And it's illustrated best by a place I used
to work.
LAREDO, Texas When I worked there in the 1980s,
there were a hundred thousand people.
There were three television stations that
broadcast in English.
One that broadcast or to the broadcast in
Spanish.
There were two daily newspapers in English
and two in Spanish.
There were probably four or five radio stations
that broadcast news.
Now that was thirty five years, almost thirty
eight years ago and a hundred thousand people
today there are three hundred thousand people
and there's one television station and one
newspaper, right?
Right.
That's it.
There is your problem in a nutshell.
Speaker 1: Hey, we had I'm going to give you
two examples to kind of frame this next question.
You know, you tell me what you think.
Under Trump, there was this famous incident
where he flipped out on CNN's Jim Acosta and
then had his press credential pulled after
Jim Acosta insisted on asking a question and
didn't immediately turn turn the mike over
when they tried to take it from him.
Last week, Joe Biden, or maybe it was this
week, who knows?
Referred to Fox reporter Peter Doocy as a
son of a bitch, and he may have been knowingly
on the mic, or maybe not or whatever.
What those incidents are.
They equally concerning in your mind?
Neither.
Both one.
The other.
What do they mean about the relationship between
federal government and the media?
Speaker 4: First of all, Jim Acosta is a First
Amendment warrior, and I love it.
And secondly, there were two people that had
their press passes pulled during the Trump
administration.
Jim was the first, I was the second and I
had to battle the S.O.B..
I'll use the word son of a bitch.
I had a battle with Trump that S.O.B.
three times and I beat him three times in
court to keep my press pass.
Right?
And Jim fought him to keep his press pass.
That is what concerns me.
I had to stand up in a in a court, a federal
court with my attorney, Ted Boutrous, who
was also a great First Amendment lawyer and
represented both me and Jim.
Yep.
And it was it was Ted who stood up and said,
you know, the administration said they had
to ban my press pass because if they didn't
come down on me and people like me that they
were afraid that reporters would run through
the halls mooning people.
Honest to God, they said that was what they
said.
And imagine having to defend that, taking
your time out as a reporter.
I had to sit in court for that.
Me being called an S.O.B.
by a president, I don't care.
I, you know, Peter still gets it, and I know
Peter and I have nothing against any question
that anyone wants to ask in that briefing
room.
There's no such thing as bad questions, only
bad answers.
God bless you for asking anything.
What may not be the question I'd ask?
I may think, Well, that's kind of shallow,
but it's it's always the answers that are
more concerning for us.
You know, there's the old story told of during
Betty Ford's days when there was a group of
reporters, including one fresh off the Choo-Choo
who saw her and a gaggle and the young reporters
said, Hey to your kids, did your kids ever
smoke pot?
And everybody thought, Well, that's the stupidest
question in the world, right up until the
time where Betty Ford said yes, right?
And he was brilliant.
All right.
You, you may think a question is stupid and
reflect upon and go, Well, that's a stupid
question.
But it's not the questions that matter.
It's the answers.
So I don't care if the president wants to
call me a dumb S.O.B. or anybody else.
And so he gave him access, and Peters can
still ask his questions.
So there's a difference there, a big difference
between having your press pass yanked, having
to go to court to defend it, having a president
fundamentally unknowing or uncaring of what
the First Amendment means and what a press
is there for a president and a president who
says, Hey, he's a dumb S.O.B..
I mean, I heard presidents say that pretty
much about every reporter in the White House.
So that's not they're not equal.
They're not equitable.
They're not.
There's no way they're on the same level.
And if you think differently, I invite you
to sit in court with me or Jim and fight to
keep our damn press passes and keep doing
our job.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, that is the exact distinction
I made after it happened.
The new book is free, the press, the death
of American journalism and how to revive it.
The book's author is Brian Karem.
Brian, really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: Sure, anytime.